and the rest of the country and we are
not going to rest till we get this done
first let me say the months the attack
on the Jewish community was cowardly
callous calculated and we have seen over
the last several years that there's been
a rash of attacks on houses of worship
of all kinds throughout America and our
houses of worship are targets and
they're defenseless and so bad people
hateful people terrorists angry people
choose houses of worship over and over
again
what should really alarm every American
across the country is that what happened
last night or two nights ago in Rockland
County and happened in Texas the
following night as part of a cascade of
violence and intolerance in America and
it's risen to a boiling point so we need
much stronger federal action because
we're in a crisis crisis of hate
yesterday I spoke to the FBI and
demanded they investigate the Munsey
attack and the other past attacks from
top to bottom and the FBI is good at
that I have a lot of faith in them but
we have to look at this at all facets in
terms of patterns links direct and
indirect the Munsey attack in the other
New York attack attacks in New York
prove that we need to do more it affects
not only synagogues but churches mosques
Sikh temples houses of worship of any
kind and we've all read and heard about
them houses of worship are particular
targets they're not the only targets so
we need the federal government to
strengthen its hand in helping our
houses of worship defend themselves and
in going after hate crimes in general
so well I'm here today to outline a plan
to better direct the federal strategy
against this rise in hate in extremist
attacks in anti-semitism and we asked
for two things to help us deal with this
problem in a concrete way words are
important but we have to do more than
words plain and simple and I think that
unites all of us here first we should
dramatically increase the not-for-profit
security grants that the recent episodes
demand a surgeon these grants mainly go
to houses of worship but they can go to
other 501 C 3 s like I'm not sure if the
rabbi Ruttenberg house was a parsonage
what is it do we know but if it was it
would be entitled the synagogue was
attached to it so it probably was so it
would be eligible and second we need to
increase support for federal programs to
prosecute hate crimes
the statistics are unnerving hate crimes
are up significantly 17 percent in the
last year hate crimes against Jewish
people are up 37 percent but we've seen
them everywhere there were 7,000 175
hate crimes reported last year and a
total of 8,000 437 offenses some did not
fit the hate crime rubric and religious
hate crime composes about 20% race
ethnicity or ancestry are about 60%
Jewish people have been the most
frequent targets Muslims have been the
second most frequent targets on a
percentage basis so that's what we have
to do so let me go over to two things
there's something in the law called a
nonprofit security grant program NSG P
in fact just in this past budget I
pushed for a 30 million dollar increase
to go from 60 million to 90 million and
that lets the law and that will be
available the grant goes for two types
of things for houses of worship and
other 501 C 3s that are targeted that
are hate targets terrorist targets -
either you do infrastructure
strengthening cameras tougher doors
fencing that would prevent an attack but
it also allows the hiring of personnel
security guards and others to guard
these institutions some of our largest
institutions already do this on their
own but so many of our houses of worship
can't afford it and yet they need the
help and there's a federal
responsibility here there's been there's
been a federal hate crimes Act I helped
pass it back from the 90s but to just
have it on the books and not have it
fully enforced and not have our houses
of worship which are targets protected
would be doing words and not action so
we're proposing quadrupling the 90
million to 360 million dollars in the
next budget vehicle that comes along
which should become did they come along
every few months and the previous grant
the 32 the goings from 60 to 90 had
strong bipartisan support and I believe
this will - this will not be a
democratic or republican issue but we
need to do so we want to do that the
second part of the plan increases the
support to prosper federal support to
prosecute hate crimes this was passed
back in 2009 and signed by President
Obama but it only authorized five
million dollars for the Department of
Justice and it provides quote technical
forensic prosecute prosecutorial or any
other form of assistance that the
federal government can give to state and
local law officials in the investigation
of prosecution of a hate crime again
the NYPD is pretty good on its own I
have a lot of faith in them but you're a
smaller town you're a smaller community
you don't have a police force that can
deal with all of this and this would be
for the federal government to cooperate
with all of the law enforcement
departments throughout the country to go
after hate crimes in a stronger and more
significant way there's been a need for
resources but it hasn't been funded to
the extent it should the five million
should go up to a hundred million
dollars okay so that's what we're
proposing we have broad support among
the various religious and ethnic
communities particularly those who were
subject and I'm gonna call on some
people to speak and I think the first
person I'll call on is rabbi Nita Minh
rabbi Nita Minh comes from the Satmar
community and it was as you know they
lost I paid a Shiva call to the Deutsch
family after their loss in Jersey City
revelling good afternoon thank you so
much Santa Schumer as we spoke then and
he said that very clearly words is not
enough action I can tell you since that
tragic day and and this is unfortunately
that just two weeks later I have to
stand here again again at a press
conference talking about the horrific
violence against the Jewish community
i canti senator that you are taking
taking action and I hope that everybody
would understand the importance of
securing the community so we when we get
a phone call in the morning
is it safe to me we have 30,000 children
just in Williamsburg and the question
comes can we safely set send our child
to school will it come home safe I hope
with both initiatives we will be able to
tell them yes with a Shem cell
it will happen thank you next from the
Orthodox Union we have Nathan demon deep
deep I don't know how to say it
Dimond it said diamond but it's no
different diamonds what I always said
thank you so much Senator Schumer you
know more than a decade ago my
organization worked with Senator Schumer
and other allies in Congress and
coalition partners to create the
nonprofit security grant program that he
spoke of today we did it then out of
concern and an abundance of caution and
we did not anticipate the nightmare that
we are living through as a Jew certainly
in the Jewish community right now
Jews attacked on the streets of New York
Jews attacked in Jersey City in a kosher
grocery store and a Jewish family
attacked in their home in Muncie in the
midst of a Konica celebration so we're
very thankful for Senator Schumer's
leadership that started more than a
decade ago and his bold proposal today
to dramatically increase the federal
support to keep our communities our
synagogues our schools safe it is a very
dramatic and bold step forward there's
more that needs to be done it is
remarkable that in this country where I
think government officials understand it
their first responsibility is to keep
their citizens safe that there are so
many synagogues and other houses of
worship that have to pay out of pocket
to have police patrol or be posted in
front of their synagogue or their church
or their mosque senator schumer's
proposal will be very very helpful in
addressing this need but we also are
looking to work with state officials and
local officials and step up the
resources across the board so that
everyone who steps into a house of
worship in this country every child that
steps into a school in this country has
a sense of security and safety and knows
that they will not have harm befall them
when they're exercising their most basic
and fundamental rights of worship and
study thank you again senator Shaheen
for your leadership and now representing
the Muslim community we have Mohammad
brought rods
thank you um so the most important thing
is my name is Mohammad Rafi and I am the
CEO of capo council of people's
organization and the president of Muslim
census committee 2020 we represent over
a few hundred organizations that were
working with and Senator our heart goes
to you because you are at the forefront
of helping everyone it's not just the
Jewish community it's not just the Sikh
community but it's the Muslim community
it's the Catholic community it's all
communities and all ethnicities what
steps you have taken previously and what
you're proposing now we as a collective
group are coming together to make sure
that we are all safe attack on any one
of us is an attack on all of us and hate
is not something a child is born with
that's something at the dinner tables
when somebody makes a remark seeing
someone who's different and talking to
their children or something this is
something we need to figure out how to
have our community members to understand
and I'm tired of this word tolerance
it's respect
it's respecting each other and it's an
honor it's honoring each other's
differences that's what's going to make
it better and if we have to
with our senators help to get these
resources so be it we are going to have
security cameras we're going to have
more security and we look forward and I
hope and I really hope that others come
and join this collective group and
pushing this and others do not block
it's the senator of what he's proposing
and if they do we're going to come we're
going to be there thank you next from
Our Lady of Fatima in Astoria is pastor
DeCosta
I'm going to echo that statement of
being a hate hate crimes when we target
one person one group we target it's
targeted for us all the hate has no
reason has hate is a destructive to our
fabric in our city I'm father Daryl from
the Roman Catholic Church and part of
also faith in New York and one time we
had a campaign talking about our
beautiful city we need to work together
and when there's a events that's make a
message as send a message of a
destructive message that is counter to
unity and harmony in our city we need to
make another statement that reaffirms
our position to be United to be able
people who work together and build up
our city so I thank Senator Schumer
because our laws are very important to
help us to protect everyone in the city
as well as are working together and
sending a message and reaffirming our
message in families and in our homes and
in our institutions that we need to
respect one another and actually love
one another as proper neighbors so I
thank you again Senator Schumer for your
your support the ADL fights hate in all
its dimensions it was formed by Jewish
people but they go after everybody who's
a hater and whoever they go against
Thank You senator I first of all want to
just say I'm Jonathan Greenblatt I'm the
CEO and national director of the ADL so
first and foremost our hearts break for
the families who lost loved ones in
Jersey City and we mourn not only for
those who suffered this weekend in
Muncie but all those who've been
assaulted and violated in Brooklyn over
the past year and we've seen those
attacks step up in just the last week
and a half or so we've seen more than a
dozen anti-semitic incidents mostly
assaults on the streets of Brooklyn and
look what happened this weekend
violating a holiday in someone's home is
about as blasphemous is about as immoral
as you can imagine
and so when we're living in a moment
where Jewish people aren't safe in the
supermarkets where they shop in the
synagogue's where they pray in the homes
where they celebrate we all have a
problem
because these were indeed anti-semitic
attacks and as the senator said the
number of anti-semitic hate crimes has
gone up dramatically in recent years but
they're not just anti-semitic they're
anti-american because these are attacks
on all of us as my colleagues have said
and they get to the essence of what's
special about our democracy which is
that it celebrates and honors our
differences and that's why I'm so glad
that the governor called these an act of
domestic terror that's what it was and I
really want to applaud the governor so
number one what we're going to do here
what he's going to do increasing the
funding to safeguard at-risk institution
matters so much whether it's a synagogue
or a good whare or a church or a mosque
all people should be safe in the places
where they pray and then secondly the
technical assistance so the federal
government uses the full weight of its
power to help state and local
authorities could not be more important
because that's where these hate crimes
happen on the street and in
neighborhoods and I think it's it's a
really big it's a big deal so let's not
forget the long term solution the best
antidote to intolerance is education and
engagement so even as we step up
security we need to keep our eye on the
ball and remember that understanding one
another in the classrooms and in
communities is the best way to build
bridges thank you echo what Jonathan
said just the picture of all of us hear
from so many different backgrounds a it
says to the Jewish community you're not
alone but it says to every other
community when god forbid you're
attacked you will not be alone either we
will all rally for one another and with
that I want to call on Mohinder Singh
Taniya my friend from the Sikh community
Thank You senator
a Valhalla nirupa Kudarat case upon day
ich Norte sub jabo puja cone Ballack on
Monday you know this year we are
celebrating five hundred fiftieth but
celebrations a founder of Sikh religion
Guru Nanak who walked twenty eight
thousand miles five hundred years back
to spread the message of universal peace
and brotherhood you know we have grown
up with the values of intolerance and
secularism and that is why when
sometimes these things do happen they
really hurt us the proposal by Senator
Schumer suddenly will allow us to
accomplish lot of things but more than
that we all have always to stay united
and even in our everyday life we have to
be very proactive and very aggressive in
outreach for all the communities to get
together then only we will be able to
remove all these disparities and all
these kinds of misconceptions or
ignorance that many people have and when
they start behaving like this Thank You
senator Kumar under next we have Eric
Goldstein he's the CEO of UJA Federation
thank you for convening all of us here
today we are particularly grateful to
Senator Schumer for championing the
non-for-profit security grant program
these dollars really do save lives
we know this yom kippur there was an
attack at a synagogue in Halle Germany a
much greater crisis much greater tragedy
was averted because a short time before
they received funding the Jewish Agency
in the Federation movement to harden
their doors and to put in a camera
system but for those hardening the kinds
of dollars that Senator Schumer was
championing the tragedy would have been
much much greater much greater loss of
life we support a network of hundreds of
not-for-profits Jewish community centers
camps synagogues day schools no one
should have to walk into these
institutions in fear we
can't allow the current rise of
anti-semitism these kind of violent
attacks become the new normal in our
community so we're incredibly grateful
to Senator Schumer for these efforts
which we know they will save lives thank
you next we have your rabbi you're
welcome Silber of the a good at Israel
Thank You senator thank you for bringing
us all here together a good of Israel as
a national organization based here with
you have an office in Washington and a
number of officer on the country and for
as long as been around yet for many
years have been fighting for these
issues back to the days of our late
president by Moshe Sharett I know was
very close to Senator Schumer correct I
know my colleague in Washington Arabic
owners work closely together with Nathan
that the owe you back when these grants
were first instituted the National the
National profit security grants you know
one of the biggest enquiries of guest
mario affiliates our synagogues and
schools around the country are about how
do we access these grants and
unfortunately there's been more
applications than the funds were
available so thank you Senator Schumer
for really adding quadrupling these
grants which will go tremendous way and
enabling our communities to feel safe
and in this time we've been to many
press conferences and I'm glad we're at
a press conference where there's
actually action well they're just words
and senator you've proven yourself once
again as Astro marry you sir L and as a
show marival all of us so thank you very
much bring us together thank you for
doing this
and thank the federal government for
getting involved both in the in the
present and as well as prosecuting this
case as well which is a very big deal
thank you and now we have Yitzhak
Fleischer of the bub of community you
had to leave so last but now I think I
have everyone except David Pollock from
the Met Council community relations I
knew him in the old days
okay keeps changing
I remember when Malcolm Homeline was out
of the JCL I do too I worked for him
okay uh well we go back to 2005 we go
back further than that but in 2005 the
nonprofit security grant program was
started conceived it was started and one
of our champions was our show America
Senator Schumer and we have helped
literally hundreds of organizations
receive grants over over those years
with tens of millions of dollars back
then we started talking about at-risk
nonprofits and we couldn't have
conceived of what at-risk was compared
to what and we know the risk is today so
we're deeply deeply grateful to Senator
Schumer because what we know is that
when a member of Congress gets up and
makes a proposal it's important but when
the leader gets up and makes a proposal
it's critical and we're deeply
appreciative and all of those who
applied last year and didn't get grants
are going to be doubly appreciative of
all of your work thank you thank you
okay we'll take questions on this
subject yes yes but it's an exhibit or
existing programs we don't have to write
new programs who just increase the money
well look III think that this will get
broad bipartisan support we'll put it in
a major budget bill and it'll I have
little doubt that it would pass it did
last time no one no one objected to the
60 going to I pushed it but from the 60
going to 90 nobody really objected
because we've seen in every corner of
the country go to any state and there
will be have there will have been
violence against a church a synagogue a
mosque a temple you name it
do you have any concern that this money
could be used because we've seen video
in Rockland County of young men you know
their their limits on it certainly
provides four security guards but there
are provisions as to who these security
guards should be in terms of their
training in terms of who employs them
etc we're aware of that and these two
programs one is very small but none that
no one has brought up any a miss
spending of money the main concern is
too little money but not that the
money's going to the wrong way or being
spent the wrong way okay federal budget
okay not in not in this funding but
there there are ideas and programs to
deal with hate and dealing with that and
let me climb degrees so you know the ADL
announced last month with Borough
President Eric Adams bringing our anti
bias and to he educational programs
specifically to schools in Williamsburg
Borough Park and Crown Heights where
these incidents have happened because so
many of the perpetrators have been
juveniles to bring our anti bias
anti hate education to those kids we're
gonna reach an additional ten thousand
students mostly students of color in
Brooklyn who are the ones who are
committing these crimes because
ultimately we need to recognize the fact
that yes we need you know we need
policing and we need security but
education education is the best
long-term antidote because keep in mind
not all there have been amazing
statements of support from people of
color from african-american leaders
after these crimes happen so it's just a
few people we need to target them
education as a way to do it and when a
person of one race creed color religion
commit something and you blame everybody
else that's racism
that's what racism is
okay now I have a statement on
impeachment which some of you asked me
but I'm gonna let my friends all leave
here so they probably have different
views on that but thank them all for
coming to keep rc3 snows thanks bow
under a mixed performance by industrial
metals in 2019 2020 brings about some
interesting challenges for industrial
metals there needs to be continued